all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
uh make sure you like subscribe ring
that notification Bell
let's get started so today I was
thinking about how traditional men are
really punished in this dating market
now let me explain okay I don't
I don't have my white board with me so
I'm just gonna use the objects next to
me ta
describe the dating market so there's
really like three guys in the dating
Market three archetypes so there's one
we're gonna go make them the cell phone
because that's the most valuable thing
I'm gonna use today so the cell phone
guys are the the top Guys these are
gonna represent the men that these guys
really don't have to do much to get laid
like first date most women are giving it
to them second date right
they don't even really have to take
chicks on dates and these are the men
that are gonna have a really hard time
settling down because they've seen the
worst side of female nature they've seen
the the good girls come on to them
they've seen the
really like they're the guys that have
screwed a lot of your wives sorry guys
you know
um unless you married a virgin
that's these men the second group of men
do I want to make them the Vaseline or
the water I'm gonna make them this
because
are the the water bottles so these guys
are the husbands okay
so the husbands are the guys that have
to court the women they they really have
to do a lot in order to get married like
they do have sex they do they do get to
smash but you know they typically have
to either be friends with the girl first
they have to they have to do something
or these guys they just get it
um now and then there's these guys now
these are the guys that are getting no
play they'll maybe get laid like once a
year if the chick is drunk but I mean in
general these guys are just the sexless
ones but we're not really gonna talk
about them so typically what I see
is when Trad comes get married they're
these guys
so they'll always they'll always say the
sexless men don't exist because or like
say these guys are just not working hard
enough or doing enough in order to get
the sex because they've always been in
the category
um that
they do get sex they just have to wait
they also feel like there are good women
um you just have to find a good woman
um however these guys
um
are like no
no no no your good woman was banging me
in the Cabana in Mexico
you're a good woman like again these
guys have seen the most because they get
the most they're like top 10 20 then the
next like 30 percent of men
and typically
what I see
is
these guys think they found a good woman
and and they operate on traditional
standards so they'll it wants to be
what's going to be my lady
in this analogy my airpods these will be
the women okay so they'll find this uni
what they think is a unicorn right and
they quarter right
and boom
um she's not sleeping with him
and he thinks wow therefore this is a
good woman this is what happened to
Logan Paul this is Nina Agdal
and she's like Logan I'm we gotta wait
I'm not gonna do it because I you know
and you know historically that would be
true but we're in a modern era and
remember
she's poisoned this culture is poisonous
to us women because again we have been
given a crazy amount of attention from
the time we're like 13 14 years old
we're you know it doesn't matter if we
go to the church the media or
School whatever it is we can do no wrong
because we're women we're always in the
right and so we've gone our whole lives
never being told the truth about what's
annoying what's not annoying being told
we're more amazing than we are and
really being overloaded on attention
um okay so this is the average chick
um
yeah so she's really not sleeping with
him because she's banging her
ex-boyfriend
yup they're bath sorry this is okay but
they're they're banging right and that's
why this guy is duped because he's like
oh and so we're in a modern era
where typically
the the woman if she really likes this
guy will sleep with him quicker
because you know
and I
I'm talking in general guys there are
exceptions to every rule but in in
general right because the average chick
has all these suitors so you know maybe
or maybe she's not sleeping with other
men but she's getting attention from
somewhere
she's getting boyfriend level attention
okay does that make sense are we are we
are we with this
um so that's why traditional men are
punished because they think they're
doing traditional rules and that's why
Myron will say things like if she
doesn't sleep with you on the first date
get rid of her because at some point in
her life she has likely slept with this
guy especially over a certain age
especially knowing women's true nature
which is to never be happy and just go
for Higher and Higher and Higher at some
point she's probably shot out of her
League
now is this every woman no
are there exceptions yes but the odds
that you have the exceptional woman
are just slip and it's funny because a
lot of the guys
um
that kind of pushed this tradcon
lifestyle a lot of them met their wife
and didn't know her when she was younger
so they don't really know or a lot of
them
um kind of grew up in a different time
before social media because remember
social media has poisoned the women we
are all poison we are all ruined
um because we're used to we either have
male friends we have whatever
so that's why a lot of times not always
right exceptions a lot of times
traditional men are punished and if she
doesn't if you and if you play by
traditional rules
um you'd likely will lose the girl
because women we want to feel like we've
earned you and we had to work for you I
don't know why we're like this as a man
it logically doesn't make sense
but we want to feel like we got the best
guy we could get and when you know guy
when there's two guys in front of us
right stops you know snitching there
um there's two guys in front of us and
this guy
is making us work for his commitment and
this guy is giving it away for free we
assume this guy is less valuable
because it's like why are you so willing
to just give that away which is why
typically I really don't
in the red pill they say don't really
ask her to be your girlfriend or if you
do she hesitates at all it's like
next because women really want to feel
like we've earned that title and odds
are in the past this guy or some other
guy has made her work for it
um and that's why traditional men are
are oftentimes punished so what can the
guys really do they can go younger right
so they can go date like a 20 year old
but now you know women are racking up
bodies from the time they're 14.
so you know 15 like this is a modern era
and unfortunately so the only way guys
guys really are like okay what solution
do I have I have to just date around as
much as I can
and the woman that really wants to be
with me will work to be with me and show
me and the other problem is you know men
you know let's just say let's let me
find another
thing to represent a lady okay all right
we got these two women right these two
ladies
obviously you picked this one because
she's thinner right I'm just kidding
now you might think the more pure one is
gonna win right but what the men are
really saying to look for is the woman
that has a genuine desire for you now
what does that mean that means the woman
like when a woman really wants to be
with you
it doesn't matter she's gonna give it
all up so
girl a white might be more quote unquote
wife material
but she's not gonna give up her reli I'm
not saying you should but I'm saying
like the point is that she would right
girl a might be more wife material but
she's not willing to give up her
religion
um
she like you want the girl that's gonna
actually listen to you and trust you and
wants to be with you and that's why
um you kind of have to make girls work
for your commitment as opposed to dating
traditionally because the only way the
guy can see who genuinely wants to be
with you which is who puts in the work
and Ladies we all know when we really
like a guy
we'll put in the work
and that's why you have all these chicks
that say I just I did so much for him I
gave him my everything because she was
chasing this guy and doing everything
and then she's like well I'm not gonna
do anything for the next guy well this
guy
was your husband in a different life but
a woman will woman will always pick the
king over the peasant and unfortunately
now we have access to the Kings when in
history our dads would keep us away from
the Kings society would keep us away
from the Kings
and the Kings would look at his kingdom
and be like okay I can only have like 20
concubines I won't have 300 but really
it's like how many you hear all these
guys in the manosphere say they've slept
with 100 200 300 women so these are
wives right future wives
um so just right there that I mean those
that's just like a short-term concubine
at least in the past the concubine's got
like a little I think they got like a
community or something I could be wrong
but now it's like it's just like a 10
minute concubiner two-month concubine
and that boom gone
um yeah so that's why dating
traditionally as a guy
that's why the manosphere guys will say
if she doesn't sleep with you right away
to get rid of her and that's why they
say
um there's not really traditional women
left
um yeah because again most of the guys
promoting the marriage and family stuff
are this guys they just don't know it
you don't say this in a happy way
but you know maybe I'm wrong let me know
what you guys think in the comments um
like the video subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time